الانسان اولا والسياسه جانبا في شمال غرب
سوريا
الامم المتحده دعت الى تسهيل ايصال
المساعدات الى المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
فصائل المعارضه في سوريا
والمنكوبه بفعل الزلزال
المساعدات الانسانيه المخصصه لشمال غرب
سوريا تعبر من تركيا عبر باب الهوى الذي
تضرر جراء الزلزال
ضعوا السياسه جانبا ودعونا نقوم بعملنا
الانساني اذ لا يمكننا تحمل الانتظار
الدمار في حلب وحمص واللاذقيه وفي شمال
غرب البلاد هائل وعلينا الوصول الى هناك
من اجل تقييمه
نامل في استئناف نقل المساعدات وان نكون
قادرين على عبور الحدود يوم الخميس
والشاحنه جاهزه للمغادره
انها ازمه فوق ازمه وليس هناك معدات للبحث
والانقاذ ولا معدات طبيه ولا ادويه كافيه
هذا ما دعى اليه المنسق المقيم للامم
المتحده في سوريا
المصطفى بن لمليح
قبل الزلزال كانت غالبيه السكان بحاجه الى
مساعدات انسانيه
والكارثه الاخيره
راكمت ماساه فوق الاخرى